all of a sudden just kind of happened
so you weren't at the Guns and Roses
show last night how come he's not
talking to me Troy my god oh my god
the survivors yes yes we that's why I've
been so quiet this first part of the
break because we knew we had I got Scott
came up to me last night I saw I saw
Andrew Moss last night and he goes he
goes Rolling Stones don't get
disappointed in this reunion but it
couldn't have worked out better two
hours and 40 minutes of chippin so we
got the approval I guy found out last
night at the show from Andrew and then I
saw Scott and he goes okay Anthony can
come in it's awesome
I the first thing I did I literally got
the approval I didn't check security I
just texted ant come they were like I
was like a [ __ ] like you're the girl
who's finally gonna [ __ ] me so I'm
driving over a midnight it's just
amazing how things change because right
after that you know Scott came over to
me while you were in the bathroom and he
goes be good and I was like yeah he goes
Anthony tomorrow come here tomorrow
that's like yep you know great great
yeah good that's awesome yeah yeah we
want to use to start talking to start
the show yeah yeah but security hadn't
been told yet and that's what this whole
45 minute hold up was we tried to get
Scout signal had been sent
[Laughter]
yeah security at the desk in the front
there pretty good
they are they because Keith came with me
of course Keith
maryska and like they give him the pass
and then they're typing out I got my ID
and he's like oh we're gonna need a
supervisor like oh yes computers they
get you every time keep records don't
they they do keep Rick I thought it was
just gonna be like if the wanted posters
still on the wall there's a problem but
it wasn't so I thought okay
do you know what I thought of doing I
did I thought this occurred to me on the
way in today I thought like maybe
traversing your skull
got a curtsey when I got the estimate
maybe we should put Anthony Cunha with
oh my god I then that way they see the
name they'd be well thought of that
creep making a little cooler in here - I
turn the heat on when I came in oh well
when I walked in oh my god
yes so I we were down there for a little
while getting the security thing taken
care of and then we got the word and and
I took the elevator up with Roland yeah
and you know you got to speak with
Roland a little bit what's your little
chat with Roland and yeah yeah yeah
rolling to Paul Paul came you know Paul
came down - non-stop tell me how shitty
everything was really oh just venting
did Paul let it all out already got
upstairs oh my god it Roland just you
know yeah roll is a good small talker
because you always has to hang out with
people outside yeah so when Roland is
like you know in an awkward moment he
just kind of spills his guts so it took
you an elevator ride and a trip in the
lobby are you do you feel like you're
fully acclimated back here you've now
got just more gossip than you know it
yeah yeah I got all the gossip I'm up to
speed yeah I'm sitting you know pretty
much where I used to sit yes and yeah
I'm in we got a lot of work being done
up here though yes like there's nobody
back there we should of course that's
the old friendly face everybody wants to
say hi everyone wants to say hi sure he
should
yeah you know what I should do there
know what to do every once in a while
his autism will realize its ugly head
every once in a while 24 hours a day
oh that's great you know just the other
day on my program I was I had a shirt
that I had a change and the only one was
a Dennis falcone shirt so I wore that
house burned down it was in your face
just right there on the shirt so it's
the same thing Chester Pennington was
wearing oh my god
yeah Lincoln Park K right let's turn
what do you think of the new studio yeah
it was a different color I mean they it
is really I find insulting that you know
you you are one of the guys that helped
make this studio and absolutely
important and not only do they throw you
out they do construction so that your
position no longer it's no longer even
exist yeah
yes it's a there's no way anybody could
sit there like I kind of like that yeah
and they are changing the sanitized in
here you know the logos on the wall well
yeah yeah no one knows what's that mean
I don't know what that is what's he say
sanitized I'm gonna bring you gifts
thanks a lot then logos on the wall
would have worked but yeah they hung
your jersey up I like that up in the
rafters right yeah raised that that the
old t-shirt up into the rafters I'm very
happy about that
now when you see like when you're on the
outside because I remember like when you
first got fired you were watching the
construction happening and it almost
felt like because I would watch a show
and it felt like you were like it looked
like it was such great stuff because you
weren't here
never in the room yet nothing's been
done no the same literally paint on the
wall yeah and a different
Souls right for the most part but just
color wise and the rooks do you
recognize the rugs be different enough
no really oh yeah I noticed nothing no
Travis is behind the glass still no it's
uh it's guys familiar and I see Jim
Norton back behind the board yeah yeah
it is a weird thing but it's funny cuz
I'm so used to seeing Anthony on my left
which no one's ever said that you but
usually I sit where where where Denny is
an anther you be on my left so seeing
you in that odd I guess I've seen you so
many times on the in the chip podcast
yes yet each other across it matters
more normal and if it's easy for you to
go over there you just have to turn the
stool over load Denny what happened they
ripped all your stuff out over there
Dennis Falcone yeah where are you based
wait till you hear this tell him Danny
tell him he don't sit in a cubicle
anymore no I'm in an office no it wasn't
rock and rollin of it you got an office
I got an office this is you officers is
just les Nessman tape a door that's
right even though it's a glass door
that's right no so did you put up a you
know pictures of family and friends and
a rock and roll memorabilia I have some
pictures in there yeah I have some
things any prized possession
I have you and Keith Moon or something
no I have a picture of Sonny Bono with I
just wanted you to prize with some old
Opie and Anthony bumper sticker why's he
shirts yeah I have weird like old Oh a
[ __ ] like these giant banner I'm like
I'm not gonna do anything woman's the
cartoon characters we have animated
thing
we I guess the other day they were
cleaning up and found a bunch of stuff
and Iraq saw some stuff over the Nagle
was cleaning up and he was trying to
give it away on his uh on his on his on
his radio show account yeah I was like
fry you the the office stuff for your
radio show was prizes on his radio show
that's bad then he got caught and so
then he sent stuff to you I think that's
how it worked out yeah yeah I didn't uh
I didn't even want it like it like I'm
not a guy that's like oh I need that
memorabilia or you know any of that [ __ ]
I'm the MoveOn guy yeah you certainly
are I saw ant the day after I remember I
want to say the day after you got fight
was like to July 4th party and I'm like
I'm like dude you all right we were it
was it was you there's like a hundred
people your house and you're like five
I'm gonna do it from my house and like
you were fine yeah that was immediately
like yeah you know you had to just kind
of move on yes to that I was pretty
disappointed yeah I got the boot it was
a it's a fun gig I mean coming in here
and sitting with the likes of James
Norton yeah yeah and just laughing our
asses off on a daily basis was uh was a
great gig yeah and to build [ __ ] you
just come here you laugh with your body
not on a roof swinging a hammer right
and then you know if that goes away any
kind of like oh [ __ ] now what were you
scared we're just kind of bombed bombed
mostly but then when we me and Keith
started building up the whole compound
thing it was it was scary because
there's so much like for years all I did
was show up right and sometimes I was
like ah [ __ ] you know this is now I got
to deal with certain things and I'm not
your boy yeah the place so to speak yeah
if it wasn't for [ __ ] maresco though
you know he's the enforcer because I'm
kind of I'm the guy was like okay
alright whatever and do
that for 20 years I think is the guy
that'll get on the phone and be like hey
Rick [ __ ] did something isn't working
get that well we're fixing that no fix
it
yeah like I need that kind of an
enforcer kind of a guy so between the
two of us over the course of the years
we really built something pretty cool so
it really is cold
yeah like when you look at it now it's
only been three years yes like an entire
network with a bunch of shows and it's
got like you've got a legit beautiful
space in the city yeah in the city it's
like it started out yeah me and Keith in
my basement yeah and three years later
it's really you know it's legitimately
just it's very cool we got a lot of
things happenin to in in the fall some
big big announcements to behave all the
way yeah yeah you're getting hints gonna
be pretty insane so but I don't you know
Keith Keith look see what I told you Jim
is not the quickest on the board choice
he's all potted up the whole gangs
potted up usually Jim has to count out
loud when he's turning on him I cried I
don't know now remember yeah you did
sign a nondisclosure I did I am in today
Keith made me sign a nondisclosure
agreement for your own my own company
yeah now it's gonna be like oh just
gotta sign a nondisclosure no no no no
but yeah coming the end of August we're
gonna make an announcement we do have a
co-host for Anthony Koo Mia yeah
contract is signed okay cool yeah and
yeah yep that's gonna be the big
announcement it'll be August 21st
perhaps yeah Danny you don't want to
just admit it now Anthony and Denny show
and you know how long we had to argue
over whether it was gonna be the Danny
and Anthony show Danny and Anthony
actually sounds better like Opie that's
the deadia death II there's no y in the
Anthony yeah and then we're only
announcing it August 21st because he'd
actually doesn't get paroled until I
think October 21st you know let me ask
this has this person does he currently
or has he ever worked at or for Sirius
XM
he might have that's good he's been in
the bill could am okay all right Wow
something yeah he's been building that
could be a lot of people mg yeah he
would be a great co-host he sure would
you'd have a lot to relate to let me
give you some pointers Anthony I'll tell
you where you slipped up okay Anthony
and their conflict free life yes did you
watch the no I forgot about it I was
doing something I think I was in the gym
actually but I saw it on Drudge when I
came back I told my slipping that in by
the way I think it was at the gym I
think I was getting a pump on yeah I was
cruising in the locker room you know I
figured I actually forgot that he was
doing that oh really
yeah I like slipped my mind I went right
back into 1994 baby I was locked in it
like that again I live I was showing the
video yes yeah I never thought they
could even do that
like I thought a parole hearing because
you'd never see anybody's parole hearing
on television no one cares
but OJ is just fantastic so seeing him
sitting there and talking it was it
brought me right back by the old days
especially what a disaster the OJ trial
was being televised to the entire
justice system yeah you would think they
would not televised there's anything
else out J does in a courtroom right but
they they just know people want to say
it and they did you know when I was
watching that
seeing OJ it was like I said it brought
me right back to in the mid-90s and he
is just stupid he's very stupid he can't
you know I I'm a huge fan of Columbo
that show Columbo and the worst thing
anyone can do on Columbo is talk too
much because it's always like I just
can't understand how they came in
through the window when this and they're
like well obviously lieutenant he came
in here and you're like shut up don't
tell him anything
and OJ sitting there and it's like well
I walked in and he had a gun and
like Oh J this your [ __ ] bus shut up
yeah yes or no yes or no sorry
yes or no say you're sorry and he
couldn't blame himself it was one of
these things where everyone else was to
blame let me tell you something I had
nothing to do with trying to get my
memorabilia back and and he blamed the
entire room of people were they're all a
bunch of [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah exactly
it was and I'm watching this just going
like oh my god shut up Oh Jay but then
they let him out yeah well they paroled
about I didn't know that you'd they
paroled him on the other ones too so I
really seemed like they were going to
and like nine years for that type of
thing is probably yeah but he killed two
people yeah I did see that's not that
actually he's responsible for the death
of the two people Oh
in a civil say in a civil lawsuit he was
responsible for the dough but he's not
actually guilty of killing them
criminally yeah and that hilarious right
and he wants to a of podcast he should
he wants to a webcast and a of maybe a
vlog vlog yeah who the hell wouldn't I'm
like who wouldn't want to watch in the
log I would definitely watch it I mean
it's easy to say I would but I'd watch
right you'd have to watch that were you
were you watching I was watching the CN
n feet of it and you know they took of
did they talk about how Trump was
responsible for Jay killing those people
did when they took a break though and
then they came back to explain their
verdict yeah you know they I don't know
if all the feeds had it but they had OJ
live and his mic was on but he didn't
necessarily know he was live oh [ __ ] and
it was like he didn't say anything
terrible but it was amazing that after a
murder trial after an FX series about
what a piece of [ __ ] he was after a 10
hour documentary about what a piece of
[ __ ] he became and nine years in jail
yeah he was still life of the party
owning the room
oh yeah Jay host when you saw when his
saw him they said he was
ninety years old that one it's like oh
yeah well you're 90 and and there's like
other she's like oh seven-day cuz I'm
hot I feel Nandi Oh Jay you might
recognize Oh Jay if you ever scoop the
throat ah
somebody somebody also pointed out that
like the the parole officers I mean
whoever makes those the the judgments I
don't know yeah one of them was wearing
a Kansas City Chiefs chives tie and they
were like Oh didn't technically play for
the Chiefs of course but just that he's
that big of a football right and it is a
little odd right yeah you would think
yeah if he had a Bills tie that would
really be a problem I was thinking was
he was there any instance cuz I don't
know football from the funnyman wit was
there an instance with the bills maybe
got defeated at some point by the Chiefs
I was rolling I just wanted to keep the
mood light you want to keep good lately
we don't people to start thinking of the
people who you almost beheaded to think
of that bummer hey I don't want to be
the mayor of bummer City okay that
double murder here look I got my little
tie why didn't you have one of those bow
ties that spin around like we're gonna
allow you to not a parole hearing oh no
Jays parole hearing Oh Jay people
throats were slit yeah almost beheaded
yeah yeah that's how bad bad live that
one I guess the the Browns and Goldman
family was a little upset
Fred gold Fred so so upset how many
times does he have to get that upset in
his life said again publicly I mean yeah
yeah yeah yes watching it what the [ __ ]
how do you let this [ __ ] out
it's got to be in fury air you know this
guy killed your son
yeah and there he is like constantly
getting a break I mean nine years in
prison doesn't sound like a break but
when you kill two people yeah Brad it's
a break that's right it's one of the
great maybe if you're if you're
convicted of murder
yeah it's the best case scenario Oh
my god but it's rare that you get away
with double murder and then [ __ ] up over
a signed football yeah yeah like what a
do J doesn't he owe money to the two
families every dollar he makes they get
which is where all his money comes from
the pension but as far as because think
about it Oh Jay could sell some crazy
memorabilia yeah like he could just sign
things I picture an assembly line of
like football helmets that he just puts
on takes on takes up and he signs it
worn by OJ you could sign knives and
people would get mad ain't knives you
think that would be undue you think
people would have a problem with that
probably don't what though you'd have a
hard time finding people who would sell
it like legit sellers like it'd be hard
to you people I you I memorabilia
sellers or scumbag doesn't do that well
Oh J stuff does not do that well at
memorabilia stuff yeah okay yeah minor
sports would sell a knife yeah blood
from the murder scene like it was dirt
from you get into picture frames and
what oh yeah we get a piece of blonde
hair matter to it
as long as I get to hear the Rivera
cardboard mid story again I haven't
heard that one oh Jesus you know when he
was growing up and where was he it was a
poem ah yeah well he used to use a piece
of cardboard taped to his hand as admit
I'm a dedicated I liked it the first
three times maybe he did tell a lie I
just kept telling it but they said you
know when oj was first going through his
trial they used to you know he was
locked up obviously yeah and they would
bring pieces of football's not like full
footballs but just like Dan'l's yes when
that no it wasn't to play it was just
just the leather panel anybody squirrel
him and rolled up up their ass is that
how they get him into the joint they put
him in a cake but anyway just sit there
and signing football panels like after
panel and that's how he really a way to
do it and then and then you put the
panel you sew it back onto a football
it's such a small way to do it when they
bring the number of a jersey yeah
haven't signed the number and then so
the number on the Jersey I never would
have thought of that that's such a small
way to do it yeah yeah I'll be trying to
get full footballs in joint just up your
ass
you probably be it would be falling out
it never ends line up where we left off
and boy I gotta say in the next couple
of weeks let's just say we might have
pre-taped I just want to say that there
is on one of the upcoming chipper
podcasts Wow is here a barbaric line Wow
that is so much fun man I look forward
to doing those I mean he's so great fun
we laugh our asses off I love doing it
yeah last night was a lot of fun yeah
one is that Sunday and then ones out
that week after but there was a oh my
god oh yeah and again right back where
we were like that's exactly when when
did you stop being mad at serious about
8:40 no as a company after a while you
get some perspective on everything that
happened and you could kind of step away
and look at the overall picture and you
kind of like yeah alright I see what
they did here and it's probably your
network successful yeah yeah that's
that's another thing like I have
complete freedom to do and say whatever
the hell I want at any moment and that's
proven because I've recently been kicked
off of Twitter my Twitter account is is
permanently suspended so I went with at
Anthony Kamiya XYZ how did you get fired
from the thing that got you fired yeah
yeah and by the way I never got
suspended from Twitter for writing the
stuff that got me fired from here yeah
but I got suspended from Twitter was
cool with it but it was fine they
weren't here it has just gotten really
good they've done that too yeah they've
gotten very they've just changed their
there I got the bigger they've gotten
they've kind of just changed their MO I
was actually sticking up for my good
friend Jimmy Norton that's right there
was an article written by some slob and
come on he she works here
[Laughter]
that was in the chamber for a law my god
Falcone that was a good one [ __ ]
Danny has to play games yes some some
witch she she wrote some article about
Opie getting fired yes and her her take
on Jimmy and myself on there was was
wrong
so Jimmy was like you wrote something
court
I wrote madam your article was poorly
researched cuz she said that like when
Anthony a fire that frequent guest Jim
Norton was brought on yep liquid guests
like not that you have to know the whole
history of the show but you understand
that I was I wasn't just a guy that they
chose but all right you'll sit Nancy
that was never replaced yeah he's never
replaced I mean this show was named Opie
and Jim Norton nerd Jim Grobe which I
remember at one point the show name I
believe changed four times in one day I
was out of town and I just I wasn't here
looking at all the gossip and just
looking at Twitter and just watching the
name what is the name of this thing oh
yeah I was having a meltdown screaming
appalled but he was trying I was trying
to erase my name off the [ __ ]
television screen off all this what do
you call those things the chyron
sanitized senators that Senate is what
they do that black magic woman song
[Applause]
I decided to write something a little
more direct to her yes as you tend to do
yeah yeah I said I I said that
what's more and it would be more
embarrassing than the then the article
you wrote to be and then I wrote
something about a fat [ __ ] looking man
woman with period read you very just
watch it there yeah yeah yeah it was
just awful period period blood red hair
that's like because she was one of these
fat girls that [ __ ] dye their hair
red like that bright red so it's like
look at me Oh someone comments on my
hair everyday of course they do
cuz that's that's the change that needed
to be made right here oh yeah there she
just looks like a [ __ ] [ __ ] ready to
pop big fat sit so she I guess she got
mad and her little followers got mad and
reported me and Twitter saw that and I
was like wait a minute I didn't say she
was I said the story would be as
embarrassing as if you were that not to
say you are right my spider trying to
talk his way I don't know I died in a
[ __ ] pay me no mind list but yeah
yeah Twitter's gotten [ __ ] very uh
they've asked a lot of accounts and they
[ __ ] they're just yeah if you think
it's a forum for open discussion Twitter
you're out of your [ __ ] mind no it's
not and you know they have rules and if
you break them you're you're banished
and the [ __ ] up thing is it's been
built up into a thing that everybody has
and you have your your account and and
then they can just take it away from you
and you're kind of left I had this weird
like a lower version feeling of when I
got fired really yeah because I had that
account for years and and it's a medium
you used to talk to you yeah and stuff
like that open over the course of 10
years or something like that and and
then it was like it's gone and you're
not in the club anymore yeah it's like
wow they could really [ __ ] with you with
this whole thing when they cannot
believe it
Voight your social voice it's a wee yes
it really is because they make it so
important yeah yeah and then it's like
oh this is important you check it every
day you're commenting you know that have
you written them sometimes if you write
them and and and present you yeah I said
hey you fat [ __ ] what period blood
red no that's rather I didn't I I didn't
do that now I'm gonna wait a little
while and see guess he can write him but
then he gets stated that's their trick
like they spent years making it so that
people especially in entertainment we're
reliant on that lot yes and then they go
oh by the way you can't say anything bad
about anyone that we like yeah we're
just gonna pull the rug out from under
I'm gonna start my own social media
thing in my basement just called Twitter
yeah I hope that Twitter thing works cuz
I was thinking about filing a complaint
oh because I got a whole bunch of angry
replies from people who were upset with
me because somebody named at Anthony Koo
Mia XYZ was complaining on Twitter that
I didn't follow them yeah yes yes very
upset at the likes of Sam Rowley I think
I was yes yeah well that's the problem
once I got suspended permanently
suspended which is exiled its fired yeah
from Twitter I was fired from Twitter uh
you know the imposter swooped in the
imposter oh you know Anthony cobia they
put the same picture I had and then it
was just awful stuff you know on there
and I'm like who's gonna really believe
that I see people that I that used to
follow me following the impostor like no
you idiot they're like how do we know
it's you were you asking who's going to
believe you were posting awful stuff
well true that should've [ __ ] Travie
look at him go home run Travie Thanks
happy Anniversary Travis by the way he's
known now you and I don't want to I know
but we do move forward yes and he is now
known as the Travis dog oh of course no
you don't think I don't know that so
everyone knows that it's still very
popular he's the Travis dog yes yes it's
really the only one on that the fans
still like trash and where pray tell is
the erock well iraq is in charge of
channel but I guess he's a operation
that he's in no he's the operations
model for the game yes somehow he's
managing our channel from San Diego
comic-con now is this a show related
thing will he come back with all kinds
of dolls it's always a smart career move
when I the show that you're on
yeah it's taken off the air and you're
like but I'm still going to comic-con
though right and you got yeah like I
want to get as far away from here
without crossing an ocean right as
possible so is that what he's doing
right now he's in comic-con do you think
he's doing all like work-related duties
he's doing duties work-related
he probably lets himself go as far as
snacking he's on the West Coast you know
I know he's going through a belt
he'll be back next week next week oh no
wait he's going to another comic-con
yeah that's I thought to when he became
the full-time like channel guy yeah I
was like great we'll start having a rock
on the air yeah get updates on the
channel and stuff and I was like wait
could we get him on the air and then
they guys told me they were like we
can't he's just San Diego comic-con oh
my god we don't why he's like why would
he do that
we don't need coverage from comic-con it
wasn't serious that sent him I think
he's I think he's collecting stuff for
the it's Eric Nagel show oh okay
well as long as it's professional
professional trip right so that's he
came over to my fourth of July party
which was great because it was the party
was way too up and fun and happy so he
came in and evened it out a little bit
he brought everyone down a little bit
guess I didn't get touched
Falcone it's against stop the bike stop
the fight don't start that open invite
[ __ ] either you have an open invite [ __ ]
no I was we were talking actually I
would love for you to come on my program
[Laughter]
we were talking about Cohn and how he
should come on the show and maybe spin
some hot wax I'd like to do on on the
program like you you used to on our
program yeah we should figure that out
some fun a little party yeah I came to
your house the night when you got fired
when I was there you were there were you
you came to a party mine and and
actually spun right music and then the
police came and the police came right
yes what sting was there when you were
the perfect host
I try you want a burger that's the
perfect toast that's all it takes
from my point I did my first
get-together July 3rd so all that I did
invite you you're on an unavailable I
know I had a guests at my time yeah yeah
but I tried to get Denny to spin in mine
too but he was already booked a gig Oh
your house your place looks gorgeous
oh thank you it looked very nice
everybody seemed to be having a lot of
fun yes I would love you to come over I
would love to you should see it with the
outdoor camping chairs in the living
room what a good party I saw the
pictures yeah yeah I think you're gonna
spark up a fire right on the floor there
I had a I threw them out right away
though I didn't did yeah because yeah I
know 15 bucks a pop should give them to
some homeless piece
they're sitting on everything come along
anyway he has the old folding chairs
yeah those folding chairs unlike sticks
with the covered in canvas yeah yeah
there's like Bill Murray was sitting in
in Saint Vincent in the backyard I have
no one I don't know no we do we do movie
references 24 hours a day no that one
and that isn't one of them this is a
more recent move is it more recent I'm
not into his recent movie so Murray that
was again no that was a good what's it
about Denny yeah uh he was a fella who
lived in Brooklyn who was in it's a
drinker and a gambler and and that he
was sitting in the backyard
Melissa McCarthy was it sounds hilarious
it was a good movie it was a good movie
and he was sitting in the backyard
singing a Bob Dylan song and he was
sitting on chairs I thought you would
have known so you have drunk it was he
singing when you're yeah it sounds
hilarious because I it's a good movie
yeah it's a good movie set in Brooklyn
yeah gumption than he used to
yeah Danny don't take any [ __ ] I like it
I do yeah like that [ __ ] Paul kid he
don't take any [ __ ] no he doesn't Wow
yeah yeah yeah well Paul likes to I
he likes to let resentment build and
fester well he was in the perfect place
yeah not a resentment yeah to bubble
over yeah no no forgiveness had been
sent he was very very upset Paul so he
got a nearfall in the elevator huh yeah
a little bit it was uh I was still kind
of you know just - oh my god I'm
actually gonna walk out of the elevator
and be up here kind of a weird thing but
the lobby is very different now right
yeah it's totally all right redesigned
everything
that was a it was very beautiful but
then coming up in the elevator I was
like oh boy I'm really walking in this
[ __ ] place three years it's a while
it's a while did you know were you like
what how are they gonna react cuz it's
weird that you'd be like find out last
night that you're welcome back yeah as
soon as you get here it's like it's
gonna take 45 minutes to get security
clearance yeah I didn't know that
like snipers in the lobby but it was
just so you know I even apologized to
Anthony too cuz we got you know we've
been trying to get Anthony to guess I've
been fighting for very hard yeah yeah
and they finally just all of a sudden
out of the blue just went yeah okay you
know he can be a guest and and and I
didn't I was so eager I just text but
they hadn't talked to security I was
apologizing excited little boy I was are
so happy and they're just not making the
arrangements yeah oh I don't know I put
them but he said okay he said you said
he could come yeah but rollin really did
the right you know role and I I eat I
panic emailed Andrew Mawson Scott I
really important they would look at it
cuz they might not recognize my email
address yeah let's do I was like oh no I
got a I got a text from Jimmy last night
and I said what are you doing at eight
o'clock tomorrow morning
isn't that like a fun way to like I know
what you're doing yeah town either I
wanted to surprise him but I didn't know
these I never know where you got on it
you wanted the big news to be in the
follow-up test right you had a little
bit of popping sir
so I just said I wrote back I said
calling into the Jimmy and Sam's show
and and then goes no coming into the I
was if so that I decided to stay in the
city last night I was afraid to send an
attacks going dude come in tomorrow and
having him go
I can't I'm away I was like I fear the
rejection well I thought I did have to
juggle my schedule a bit I was supposed
to go to John Suhag today to get my hair
done
well now you can just sit on it after
this show Danny Collins I just said you
stayed in the city listen yes I did you
didn't bring your cab
right is that now he's like he's like on
fire a little oh yeah and he's gonna
keep attempting into like you know only
if it's right I like it I'm working he's
got moxie we're two professionals I like
that he mailed me that he did yeah he
got me good
no I've I've kept my photography to Long
Island good the nice neighborhood nice
neighborhoods of Long Island yeah here's
the worst part boy monday morning
they're just gonna hate me in Sam again
it happens we I mean look I know I'm
probably the only one that doesn't get
any hate on the Internet you don't you
do oh I saw my favorite of all time is
Tran PAH
that's one of the funniest ones yeah
translates finding Tran theny is funny
but Tran Pau was one of the like I read
that I'm like Larry man right grandpa
right and then it's like you know I've
had friends that are of transgendered ñ
ñ anam Tran PAH
right yeah that's so thank you how did
you skip a generation that you're more
tolerant to trans people than you are to
black people have you ever been robbed
to play a trans person I have my old
views of myself face down in the pillow
Jim Norton and put the new one in
apparently going oh what's that the
names are funny the tree made me laugh
and then apparently I'm going broke I'm
spending all my money on combat media
keith is bilking me of it Keith did you
hear the latest one we have we fired the
cleaning staff because we couldn't
afford it and now we have Garrett and
John and Allie cleaning up the studio
really they should be yeah yeah exactly
yeah the latest one ruins an iron fist
yeah it's so fun so this co-host
announcement
yeah August 21st is going to be very
lackluster if you guys you got no cash
that's just it it's you know we had to
really go down on the scale of people
it's act okay I'm going to announce it
it is Bobo oh he's been here oh no how
great would it be if hon announcement
day you announced Bobo as a joke didn't
tell the audience at first girls didn't
tell both the audience found out at the
same time oh my god that is a joke be
great oh Jesus then we just leave the
window open for him to jump out of I
really do it I was oh I
okay yeah yeah you know it's funny it's
really funny but could I get paid anyway
was Bobo your biggest win in the in the
OPM the custody battle yeah big a the
big I got big a and I got Bobo and and I
think I got a little bit of stalker
patty but didn't patty we've had a
committee no yeah yes she did both she
was like yeah joint custody she yeah she
got she's recently retired did you hear
about that I'm Starbucks yeah she came
on my show Andrea she announced her
retirement from Starbucks I get a
pension check and I get a pound to
coffee every month what every week I
think really yeah I said she should set
up a little coffee thing for cheaper
than Starbucks right in front of a
Starbucks coffee well she's not going to
try living in them yeah after eight
years of [ __ ] coffee things yellow
house yeah she's come in Patty's came in
yeah I've heard from Pat from una Pat
was on my show like last week well I
miss Pat last weekend at two he kind of
co-hosted and it was great
it was hilarious we went over his whole
will his father's will did you see that
no oh my god it's [ __ ] tragic huh his
father remember he was searching for his
father George for so many years and he
finally like found
out who he was and where he was and
everything because it's his father
ditched him when he was like six months
old or something or a year old so his
father recently died he's somebody a
relative said hey check the the
newspaper out that's your dad and it was
you know whatever his name is
you know Philbin and Regis he was Regis
Philbin and he was a guy that was in
construction and ironworker and stuff
like that so the will comes out and I
guess a lawyer had sent a Pat a copy of
the will and there was one line in the
will that said for reasons known to
myself my son I have had I have
intentionally oh oh you have it they
read it for reasons known to myself I
have intentionally not made any
provisions for my son Patrick Philbin
who in this my last will and testament
that's in there that's not even like I
forgot to put you in or didn't put you
in it was specifically put in to to not
give him anything [ __ ] Wow never have
the answer as to why that's there me
maybe someday he'll have the answer on
the other side in heaven in heaven where
he joins rejoins his toes cruel guy that
is the most brutal [ __ ] thing you
could bet that's a [ __ ] you to the
mother or something like that that's
gotta be something like that yeah Pat
speculated that see Pat has this
half-brother and he built to the father
out of some money and the father was
under the impression that it was Pat
that did it and that's the only that's
the only thing back to think of that
though do you know the reason I was on
the road with Kenny one time and we were
getting contacted by Pat from Moonachie
for money and passes true right and I
was gonna give it to him and then a
patch that I did again I'm going by I
think Pat said it was his brother yeah
me I remember I didn't leave that true
some possibly maybe he did okay maybe he
did the I was Pat that could be that's
the only speculation and that sound ill
it's just like oh maybe he thought patch
stole from I mean yeah yeah what a
bummer
poor Pat is we've been after he died the
father just had to stick him one more
time yeah yeah well maybe he thought
that maybe Pat thought that and the guy
thought Pat stuck him first
yeah yeah you know but I mean it's your
son you got it and you should look into
that maybe and see really who screwed
you over before you just in death [ __ ]
the guy like you just decide oh you just
leave and not even give the answer for
reasons known to myself to come no
provisions had this good day sir and
then the most important in the divorce
we did get sandy Kane we got sandy Kane
all got her - yeah oh you did okay all
right yeah yeah
by the way I've seen her every night
sorry to hear that oh we did almost kill
her the day that I pulled the chair out
that is true Chris Gethard
yeah his shows coming to truTV yeah and
the promo that they play is a clip with
her on the show she's oh I know she did
a show that's why she started emailing
us but they're playing it like every
half hour
really Wow yeah yeah she's gonna be
famous
no she's not so if you don't want to see
sandy Kane don't want yeah yeah at 5:00
Times Square oh you know I guess she
like she's there and and the guy there's
there's worse things that have happened
in Times Square
oh well yeah well that's another thing
like I yeah I've been fired from Times
Square and then people got run over and
stuff like that and I all right I walk
through there because sometimes I do Oh
actually tonight 5:00 to 6:00 tonight
I'm doing Tom shall lose radio show on
Fox News Radio oh yeah Tom's great I
think he's a blast but when I do
kennedy's show sometimes on fox
businesses and then I walk to my studios
in in the 30s over there and I have to
go right through Times Square and I'm
just I I recite how angry I am out loud
oh look at this piece of [ __ ]
walking by because it's loud and no one
can really hear you no one pays
attention any individual conversation
mad about everything okay people yeah
yeah and assessment tours the friggin
Mexicans dressed up in their elmo
costumes oh yeah it really is a cesspool
it's not here works best no no like they
you know how they say they cleaned up
Times Square and it used to be porn and
everything and stuff like well cleaned
up isn't they just put a new type of
garbage in there and that's what it is I
just look and I see like I'll see some
guy I saw some guy that was obviously
from another state in the Midwest
somewhere he's standing there he's got a
[ __ ] handful of money and there's
five stuffed characters around him
pointing at his money with one hand one
guy and then individually pointing at
each of the stuffed animals and I knew
what was happening right there no no you
have to pay him him you took a picture
with all of us so if they're shaking
down people in there and it's just I
hate them I hate the person that's being
ripped off for getting ripped on the
ripped off one is that they taking the
picture with the kid or whatever they
have to tip as if it's voluntary yeah
yeah there that says that yeah yes a
sign meanwhile you not do yes is let's
say you're gonna get a photo with Mickey
yeah then everyone who's around you will
jump into the photo and then you take
the picture and now you owe all of that
now you're six people it's all scams
going on we don't have to just walk away
not too many they've been people have
been assaulted for walking away in Times
Square
yeah you know what are you wouldn't let
your [ __ ] kids near those stuffed
guys
the second they took their head off it's
totally Tony Montana's under the [ __ ]
thing since he doesn't gangsters some
people think that they're part of Times
Square like oh this is nice like when
you can buy this city
exactly I never even understand why
people go to Times Square
like like once you take a picture of
where the ball drops in [ __ ] New
Year's Eve like this it's just what
you're gonna go go to Bubba Gump shrimp
it really is not the same here used to
be but Gump shrimp you wouldn't go there
no why not it's just like the movie it's
so the movies playing it like every time
I pass by it I just again out loud I'm
like who the [ __ ] is going in this [ __ ]
old and
I'm store you don't go into I want to go
in there but early twenties of the
people take pictures of the sign the big
neon or like it's a very nice really
impressive yeah great great architecture
building it's great we're Big Apple errs
we take it for granted cos we're big a
blurs the work with the gap little early
yeah but somebody from another place I
mean they don't get to see this stuff I
don't know it's just people are trying
to work get out of the way you don't
think it'd be fun I think to go into
bubblegum shrimp and just start listing
off the possibilities of different
shrimps you could have I wonder how many
people do that get on them start reading
the menu go watch watch fresh shrimp
popcorn shrimp or shrimp scampi look I'm
like Bubba I wish you are dead it's
terrible you don't think that the the
waitstaff is like oh this guy's actually
quite clever and then in between that
there's just a bombs the bums are back
with a vengeance they really men and
then since that maniac drove down the
street and killed that girl and ran a
bunch of people over right they decide
to put the police big giant NYPD
concrete blocks on the sidewalks and you
gotta walk in between them yeah which
isn't that much of an inconvenience
until you add the bums sitting now on
the concrete blocks so now you gotta
walk between bum feet stand it you know
there's a guy on feet there's a guy who
gets who gets that's Oscar Pistorius
head
there's a guy who is it my subway stop
who he smells like piss I'm surprised I
didn't get beaten up for that way but he
has like one of those big bolt like the
front of his pants looks like he has a
30 pound water balloon like what the
[ __ ] is that what is that it's almost
like it's not like a dick bulge it's
like some kind of a giant tumor you ever
watched my 600 pound life
yes that's like they show them naked
because nothing shows they're covered by
their own flesh in the shower and you
see where all those things are and what
they are they're just big rolls of giant
fat don't look good now it couldn't not
elephantitis of the ball i know it might
be do it really does look like that yeah
those things as a kid she's also funny
we should take a break we have a
break-in Jake breaks here yeah Wow we do
when out loud I know right and and we
have a guest coming in yeah we are
dealing he's coming in he's great he
wasn't the mystery guest we was already
booked that's fantastic funny
[ __ ]
yep so we have an tol 11 yes Daddy he's
already gonna sit
that's a great question maybe on Monday
Moretz cos giving up his seat oh you
know what we're gonna want to sit out
there a while I'll go I got work to do
all right well what could we say Anthony
Kumi is finally back in studio guest and
uh let me say thanks for joining us so
much fun could say well you should stay
through the break oh please of course
and we got a we're going to Montreal
next week and I got my [ __ ] you wanna
come with us to Montreal I would love to
come I missed that right after I was
like oh I'm so glad they after I was
fired they didn't in protest you guys
didn't go to Montreal and do the comedy
that you know it was kind of nice
solidarity and they and then it was like
oh they did go yeah and I had to listen
and I'm kind of like I'm hearing stories
and all the comics that was at Billy bar
and everybody and I'm like oh this is
great
it won't believe me it wasn't this fun
it wasn't no I'm so glad when we get
back I want to talk about like all this
stuff especially early on I would
imagine that you heard about that
sounded like this amazing thing yeah
well the rest of us knew it was just the
same [ __ ] as always
yeah yeah that's what I want to know
about and we'll be back with can't
believe I'm saying it we exactly
Anthony Kumi
[Music]
show me the help there he goes one two
one two three watching you work that
bored so cute well Sam I know I'm
getting better at it but I didn't have
any formal training no everyone else had
formal training or exam as an intern
they trained years ago I've never
trained so I kind of learned on the
flies we say yeah I never had any formal
training but they showed you it's not
many buttons on it that's you yeah it's
pretty it's pretty much but you get a
ride you get a ride the just down for
quieter and up for louder I don't know
why I would pause for so long after that
it was an error on my part well I know
camera here's that no well yeah that's a
360 cam they just threw in here too I
guess to see what what they got
Anthony Kumi is in studio this is a very
special day it's a very happy I was just
looking at Twitter during the break and
then this people uh people is seem very
happy yes very happy to hear us all
yapping together and anybody that is not
able to because you get to run into work
we obviously we replay at least for the
time being it's not gonna be forever but
we are replaying from 3 to 6 so you can
catch it if you know people who haven't
heard the whole thing can catch this
afternoon yes and we're on demand I'm
Ron oh yeah unda man I keep forgetting
on demand is the thinking that a pout
get us on demand yeah I just forget yeah
have you seen what Sammy Sosa looks like
now yeah do you see him with it's like
an upstanding citizen remember years ago
though like even during the McGwire Sosa
thing that was good he was kind of
lightening up and people were like hey
is he getting lighter and then he
disappears for a while he comes back and
he's uh yeah now it's very very very
light you expect me to believe McGwire
hit those home runs
[Laughter]
does he hit a like oh by the way no he's
also wearing the the pink suit with his
with ah yeah with the pink bowler hat is
that what he's doing he's doing that
look what's he doing it for look at
while he's second
people are saying you know there's a lot
of of self-hate involved in the
Dominican community and all the sir he's
saying that he uses lotion to soften his
skin and it just happens to also I guess
lighten it a little bit he says yeah
that makeup he's wearing hers out his
skin that's his skin it rubs the lotion
on the Dominica he yeah I think he took
his melanin and gave it to oj oj is a
lot darker than he used to be in jail
you're in prison yeah well I'm out in
the yard a lot yeah I'm on your show if
you could I believe really so so Jay so
Jay
oh hell yeah I'd hire the guy yeah the
way social looks now okay try to date
him
we met some hire the guy I'd hire him in
a second when everyone else says no we
say yes yeah when you're would you banks
there's no champion champion yes when
everyone else in broadcasting says no
compound media says yes we were actually
in a meeting with Anthony Weiner say it
again we were actually in a meeting with
Anthony Weiner Weiner what about Anthony
Becca Bock yeah there's the joke chibok
next time damn it next time you're good
but the Anthony Weiner thing did not
work out no it didn't but I know your
co-hosts won't be because Anthony
Anthony was a little delusional I think
oh no yes I've said that before
yeah so wait I do did you actually meet
with him too oh yeah okay how was he
playing he's he's a weird guy
yeah I don't have to say like he's he
can't concentrate
he's very jittery he
in with the baseball hat and the
sunglasses on because you know he's his
skirt I guess yeah but we sat down and
talked about you know him doing a show
well he's also wanted to be the mayor
and invention of the governor like he
was a power driven guy whose apologies
yeah yeah and now he's looking at
himself like I'm meeting with the guy
who showed my penis photo it started the
yeah at the beginning of the end I just
I just took a shot and I emailed him and
I said hey not sure what you're gonna be
doing but if you'd like to have a voice
in the platform we would be interested
in in having you and I see seed Anthony
on you know Anthony ku me on the email
and afterwards I texted I'm like there's
absolutely no way and he emailed me back
yeah so him and I got together and we
met in bed with your rods through the
underwear I didn't like that Anthony
ruined that picture by being in it and
then you know we agreed to meet the
three of us and we went out to lunch and
we discussed having something on the
network and yeah it's not that it didn't
come to be because we were going to
continue talks and then and then it
really kind of got bad for him right
like for I don't give a [ __ ] if he's
sexting and getting kicked out of his
[ __ ] job and divorced and everything
like that but then when it was like oh
wait a minute
kiddie porn charged allegations and
stuff all you need is two of those on
the network we do draw a line basically
enough there is a line and amazingly
enough that's what it is yeah yeah
everybody we would be like I I could
literally have OJ on sooner than yeah
Anthony Weiner at this point did he know
that you guys leaked the photos come up
in the conversation but I can't imagine
he didn't know that yeah the first time
when I met with him and he said so this
is Anthony from Opie and Anthony and I'm
like oh this is where he said how the
[ __ ] do you think I would have
thing to do was so much bad stuff has
happened since then that's worse than
that yeah because he could have survived
that he literally could have survived
that was just that that coming back and
he [ __ ] up again but that was
survivable yeah he and he said you know
what I really like those guys and I was
like wow maybe we have a shot at this
Wow and when we sat the three of us you
know and they started talking I mean we
know Anthony can talk to anybody
Anthony yes we do know that yeah and I
sat back and I watched them and I well
we offered him his own show but then we
talked about even them doing a crossover
together because they were very
comfortable you know it was odd it was
weird right he's sitting right there and
you're like that's the guy yeah there he
is and he and this was during the
campaign
the Trump campaign and everything and
where the news was coming out about him
and his computer and Huma and Hillary
not really no you can just he brought up
some of the stuff he's just like yeah
he's my computer's know that like he
actually talked about his computer I'm
like oh he's talking about that thing
the computer that everyone's talking
about yeah you didn't ask follow-up
questions so when somebody like I feel
like when I'm having a conversation is
somebody start saying things that
they're not supposed to yeah I just jump
in like you opened the door now it's now
you're out you're like [ __ ] Mike
Wallace yeah that's right he was
[ __ ] over the course of doing this
we've heard we've talked to some
interesting folk been an ear an ear call
because I know you did manage so you
missed Anthony Weiner you good sir you
managed to land a Dave II saw David on
the east side Dave show is I don't even
know what it is still right I watch it
it's like some kind of twisted
nightmarish version of pee-wee's
Playhouse where
destroy your set they destroy my set
yeah yeah he gets a producer here's how
each side depicts his producer for a
show when one producer leaves and it's
usually they're fired on the spot or
they there's a fight or something
whoever's sitting in the audience he'll
pick a new producer from the audience
you know who his producer is now who no
big a oh wow that's the guy is he sad to
his producer because beginning a was
there and kind of got up to protect his
side Dave when his previous producer got
up and flipped the desk over looking to
kill East Side Dave McDonald I hope that
I hope I'll hope he doesn't need his
producer to talk about a stop set that's
gonna be a TV a long break so big a he's
doing it now yeah big a's doing that
well I think I hit the table I mean I
understand probably above you know get
to someone if he's trying to the guy
fancied himself as a stand-up comic so
he got up there and started doing some
stand-up comedy and Dave did not find it
funny Dave the objective toohave let him
know that it was not funny the guy got
pissed said he was gonna start kicking
Dave's ass and Dave said you know back
and forth hey [ __ ] you and that was it
it came over and flipped my $8,000 desk
over did it break a little bit they
fixed it did you charge him we had text
messages saying that he admitted to it
and he would make restitution but man we
haven't really seen no real restitution
you have yet to collect
it's like saying oh what the video guy
here is gonna get paid right why Paul oh
I heard that one though he well he never
got any was supposed to make a few bucks
really a branch I I it's funny I
actually just sent Paul a check because
of some stuff he did for me for Comic
Con
oh really yeah a little study wouldn't
rice no but I got a big I was doing a
little something I felt that to me yeah
yeah yeah hot dog has has earned a
little bit of money for doing wrestling
things for me yeah you got a man these
guys are doing some stuff I see you on
that
WWE every so often there Sammy Roberts
as a matter of fact I'll be on the WWE
Network this
Sunday no you can't do that I'm gonna
need you to do something that's too bad
unfortunately you can't do that at the
battleground kickoff show oh really
live at 7:00 p.m. Eastern it's very good
on that in the WB network in saw Jim
Duggan gonna be there he won't know I've
don't Oh God my my stepdaughter and her
boyfriend or a big wrestling fan
oh and when they found out that I am
friends with the likes of Sam Robert
come on it was very very exciting really
like Sam oh they love sin which disgust
fury hates men
disgusted keith is a guy who's known me
since I was an intern helping him with
homeless people
all right that's tearing the shopping
sprees and stuff and now yeah the
homeless shopping spree now they'll
intern boy how you have climbed that
ladder with just a mass of bodies
underneath you
yeah if you really do leave some [ __ ] in
your wake yeah he's been walking over
[ __ ] skulls on his way up yeah we
don't we didn't rise peacefully that is
it may I look around and it's like okay
I see Travis a dog so the Travis dog and
Sammy Roberts and Jim Norton it's like
that's pretty much like it from the
original original yeah yeah yeah a
journal original there's really no in
57th Street
we got Garrett a tricky statement from
any W but he was not a part of this show
no but he was over what was he working
with J times J Thomas do you him in a
song a Thomas did awesome Garrett yes
yes um Garrett saw from that's from 2001
maybe oh my god so long ago awesome
Garrett he's great yeah I'm had fun yeah
he's he's just a good guy he's guy very
I could I could talk to him on the air
and he does just sit there Dyer and it's
nice did you ever panic when you're
doing your own thing and it's like it's
all you and then keith is doing it with
you but I mean like you're it's like
you're your network and what are you
like oh my god it's gonna collapse it's
not gonna make it or you get to a point
all right it's cool man we're gonna be
fine yeah early on you know it was I
don't know if this is gonna work it was
such uncharted territory so uh yeah now
the
it's it's moving along knock wood very
nicely and you know things are happening
so I don't have that hold you know oh my
god it could collapse at any second
right right right
but yeah doing the show alone isn't that
tough either I like doing it alone
sometimes I like the shows by myself
just be able to [ __ ] about anything
like Alex John that I do Infowars it's
amazing if I do Alex Jones Show every
other Thursday from 3 to 4 p.m. he
leaves and I take over his show for an
hour it's incredibly yeah you doing Alex
Jones of show now yeah yeah have you
mm-hmm
looked any more closely yeah at building
siete which is Spanish for seven oh my
god building seven yes you know they
were the fire department was told to
stand down I remember I remember at one
point a lot of the theories that were
brought up being a whimsical almost I
here's my take on 9/11 a bunch of filthy
animals decided to get on planes and
crash into buildings there that's it
there wasn't any conspiracy you know
there what what did they know did the
American government know American
government well of course the CIA
planned the whole thing absolutely don't
there's actually footage of that one of
those guys who allegedly died he's a
pilot in another airline oh okay
computers haven't picked that up with
this that would be a little
nerve-racking looking into cockpit and
be like oh yeah it's familiar
yeah but yeah doing the Alex Jones thing
is hilarious it's like non-stop you have
to talk there's like segments there's a
five minute and a ten minute in an 18
minute segment where it's just looking
at that camera and rambling for 18
straight minutes and I mean not
conversationally you're just flutter
liberals right globalist rhetoric and
it's once it's done and we go to break
I'm like I have no idea what I was in
saying is he a bullet points it is
amazing that Alex can do that to look
into a camera and like just to be able
to go that means
[ __ ] incredible - yeah it's hard to
do it's not an easy job because it's
after we're done it's exhausting I'm
like oh yeah and but it's fun it's a lot
of fun it's a it's a totally different
thing than doing my show sure and it's
like right after I do it I go to do my
show and the difference is just stark
but it's so much more relaxed doing my
show and that is all pumped up and this
show every day he does his show for how
many hours it seems like 12
there's just yelling at globalists and
[ __ ] contrails in the sky and yeah I
guess he does a four hour show so it's
um 12 to noon - for something like that
and like I said every other Thursday
from 3 to 4 he leaves but it's funny
it's like alright taking over now for my
show is Anthony cou Mia Anthony coming
from combat media is gonna be on here so
take it away Anthony and I'll be like
alright boy did you see on the news
today Fox News was actually saying that
sessions jeff sessions with Anthony let
me cut in here I was just eating my
lunch and I wanted to say I heard you
talking and and I'm just cracking up
Anthony I was just pouring my chicken
noodle soup out of my thermos and what I
think is that Europe the European Union
so you know it's maybe it's 3:15 to 4 I
get to talk I mean it's so great that
part I love that partnership - you and
Alex Jones partnership is it really
isn't it your opinions on various
conspiracies have not shifted terribly I
you've had Lionel on the show right no I
like vinyl he's out of his mind crazy
because he was on and he's very
articulate and concise and he researches
things but he believes that aircraft in
this country our spraying [ __ ] out and
that's what the contrails in the sky are
the vapor trails okay he honestly
believes they are trying to change
the atmosphere putting stuff in the
atmosphere to block the sunlight and
trap in the greenhouse gases or
something and he believes that and I'm
like you so you're telling me that that
airliners with people on them everyday
are doing these covert missions where
are the tanks and spray nozzles yeah
we're the people to go hey I'm just
going to Pittsburgh
what spraying out of this waiting but
but he honestly believes it things like
that those conspiracies I'm like are you
out of your [ __ ] mind it's fun to
listen to and it's amazing that people
can talk about them so much yeah like
they're Alex Jones you have to say is is
a real genius he's a bona fide genius
because come on whether you're right or
wrong to be able to be interesting and
talk that much yeah for that long
decisively without a whole lot of none
of that yeah I mean every time he's got
more to say like there's a brilliant
study for your mind to work that well
you know he's talking about football
he'd be scott ferrell who's another
genius to be able to talk about sports
that well for that long I'm sorry it's
[ __ ] you're you're a bona fide genius
to do that he's and he's like
impassioned for yeah every minute he's
on he's just on eleven yelling into that
mic and now you look at what he's
yelling about it's like really yeah have
you met him physically or no um once a
while ago but no he's in Dallas right
he's in Austin Texas
yeah he's in Texas if I ever go down
there I would want to meet Alex Jones
when I'm down I'm gonna do a gig down
there and I didn't care I do a show we
just like to meet him you know if he
knows he's like a comedy fan yeah knows
you as a comedian I I don't I know he
knows me from the show he would
recognize my name just remote being
Anthony I mean I bet he knows you as a
comedian our buddies we have a lot of
similar friends I know you're the whole
LA venture a thing we're him right cuz
he's friends with Jesse Jesse hasn't
been on his show though in a long time
he hasn't done this I'm I'm off the grid
I'm off the grid and I'm doing a show to
tell everyone I'm off the grid I live in
Mexico every six months out of the year
I moved to Mexico to get off the Julia
he's the most on the
off-the-grid guy I've ever seen he
really does pop up to let you know that
he's not gonna tell you not you can't
track me down yeah really
he's eight yeah all over the place hey
no one's looking for you Jesse where you
are with of course is riffraff yeah he
can't look at it without thinking that
yeah I really have put a label on him
that he's never gonna shake never well
no he's gonna shake never see him yeah
let me check yeah is he a disaster
certainly is yeah but I would love to
have him on again interview and I think
someone told him like hey man those guys
actually turn around and say that they
believe that you were wronged I believed
him in the Chris Kyle oh really that
Kyle was bullshitting or something yeah
only believed Chris what he said on the
show but after Jess when I heard Jesse's
expert I sometimes you just hear someone
explain something and when we heard
Jesse on Alex Jones explaining he just
sounded like a guy who was telling the
truth it was mind control from the heart
system in Alaska was it I was a fighter
a Navy SEAL I wore a feather boa that
[Laughter]
happened here what was the like you're
talking about the comedy festival yes it
happened three years ago like right
after you got fired yeah I was I was
like I'll [ __ ] I want to go to that's so
bad
what was this stuff because I think if I
remember right when Foo Fighters came in
here you were pissed I would see the
guests that were coming through here and
I was like where the [ __ ] were these
guests when I was on the gun the goddamn
charnel I thought of you with Arnold so
I was a goddammit - I wish Anthony was
here Arnold there was so many I would
listen to and I'd be like ah god I would
just like go on about [ __ ] like one
movie one character the most obscure
thing like that's the [ __ ] I used to
love doing with a remember when Dennis
Quaid called in and all I would talk to
him about was the movie bill [ __ ] a
horrible movie made in like 1980 that
was good he was a kid but he was
cracking up because he's like who the
[ __ ] even remembers it is Mickey Rooney
played the [ __ ] guy and he was the
guy that helped
was doing a documentary on him and he's
like how do you even remember this I'm
doing the lines from the show we had a
main actor came in and I was doing the
Wrath of Khan scene through the glass
yeah like that [ __ ] and there's so many
guests that have been on your show and
and on the Opie whatever that was called
who no I'm whatever day it was that it
was like [ __ ] that I would have loved to
have talked to her well now that do you
now we will we can give you some advance
notice of yes and if there are people
you would like to interact we can have
Anthony as he guest come in and there's
plenty of people I would love to have
Anthony I was [ __ ] miserable in Arles
you're like [ __ ] that was perfect for
that was a he'll be promoting a good
movie was called Maggie was that well I
saw that with a kind of indie kind of
zombie he's a great night he was good
that was great like that I loved him in
that and we've had some I say Roland has
done a great job really great job
getting us the guest and uh the ten to
eleven hour long how does he get guest
when he's in HR all the time that's a
good time I think because I you know
this hours when they're done with like
Katie or Kathie Lee where the [ __ ]
they're doing and Jota did you Kathleen
Hoda they do live with whoever's left oh
really so they do the round and then
they come here ten to eleven we get some
great ones man that's also that's right
Jason I don't know Ellis thick because I
always wanted us to move on set up an
hour earlier and I told him that it was
I tell this to reason I don't wanna get
an hour earlier I mean I want to lose
these guests in this hour it's amazing
you're making what like sleeping in cuz
you know all that action and
skateboarding I'm friends with Jason
Alice is tough for an older guy we made
up
you deadly amazing [ __ ] you guys give
him a beating like sometimes we just got
to take it yeah but you know it's one of
those things where like the hours or
cert you know how it is man like the
longer you go in life it's hard I'm
forward to turn 49 getting up in the
morning after doing stand-up at night my
body does not recover it I know boom oh
[ __ ] you about you're right it's it's an
easy job I went to bed I mean that's
just being the mirror yeah
I went to bed last night because Agni
was so late I went to bed like [ __ ]
1:45 2 o'clock and I used to get all the
time when we were on 6 to 11 yes and I
would go to bed late and I'd [ __ ] it I
did get four hours a night that would be
loopy but again it was you and Opie and
I was chiming in so it was a little bit
of an easier gig than this is I'm still
you yeah I would I would my schedule
here was insane cuz I would drag down
with the ship I would drink a lot get on
with the show and then go home and nap
like just which was really sleep it
wasn't even a nap right it was the
night's sleep in the afternoon wake up
hang out at night would ever go out
party [ __ ] and have people over the
house whatever it was and then take a
real short nap between whenever I went
to sleep and had to get up again and
come here your schedule gets crazy
mister eight in the morning is but for
you to be hard for driving without
taking mass yeah but now [ __ ] getting
up at 7:00 and being on my ear is a way
to like live and I can do it and not be
[ __ ] crazy it's also that last hour
though because I don't give that much of
a [ __ ] about the schedule I do whatever
you wanted to do obviously you don't
mind waking up I don't care yeah for me
it drives me I can't fight anymore I
wouldn't want to give up
[ __ ] that 10 to 11 hour because like you
said that's when all the guests come in
here and I was like yeah let's move to
seven because I don't give a [ __ ] but
then I went over and looked at all like
the big people we've had in and 90% of
them come in between 10:00 and 11:00 and
so you got to be here at that time it's
just weather in the building I picked a
very scientific method to figure out
when I was gonna be on the air because I
am on from a 4 p.m. to 6 p.m. Eastern
time this you are Monday through
Thursday it's a great it's an amazing
schedule really I figured it out because
I was like when can I be up pretty much
it I think you really have to be a
complete [ __ ] to not be able to be in
by 4:00 which by the way is is ironic
that you say that because
so I think the last time we were at your
place we were recording at 3:30 and you
were late yeah vacation show we came in
yeah and you were late to my own house
yeah that was yeah yeah at the house 358
959 I would run down the stairs with my
pajama bottoms still on my god to do the
show because it was like no I I'm home I
don't have to but you know traffic you
figured out though you were like as long
as I can start the show at 4:00 p.m. and
I do the show that's it I'm okay I'm
fine no problem well we finally thought
it would be better to get a studio in
the city yeah and I would I would
actually leave the house Rand and oh
yeah how does some type of interaction
with humanity I used to love those early
compound days oh yeah when it was like
because my dad would watch and he'd call
me hey cuz he watches everything and he
called me and he go what's going on with
what do you mean and he goes well you
know I love him but like I was watching
today and he said that he went to the
bank and he did a half hour and going to
the bank because this is the first time
he's left the house in four days oh yeah
I would just not leave the house so it
was it was kind of not I I am taking the
Long Island Rail Road in much it's much
easier to use [ __ ] you adding years
to your life though without [ __ ]
sitting in traffic oh yeah that could
all be taken with a stabbing Jesus those
people is it is the traffic bad coming
from coming from Long Island no it's not
bad when I leave at like 6:00 or 6:30 or
whatnot it gets a little dicey
[Laughter]
are you coming in yes
[ __ ] arty man you look good right
like that already looks thin lost some
weight you are you look thinner dude
you're making a conscious effort I've
never done radio before push them push
me off on the law did you lose 80 pounds
but I'm a slice of pizza away for being
a jonbenét keep doing out I start yeah
that's true you're gesturing with your
water no I came out it's always like I
go through that two-wheeler that's it
I'm gonna be I'm wearing kettlebells
pick them up but I was 15 I lifted away
once I looked one time I live in a curl
I put it down and said I'm never doing
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
the woman doesn't like this is from the
hospital I swear to God oh and I forgot
that I was more like a long-sleeved
shirt which is you know a junkie luckily
in July but no I feel good though you
know so I missed the interview with
Chris Christie I missed an interview
with I overslept with anybody the
governor of New Jersey I was supposed to
go you know when you do Caroline's I
don't know if you've done that Jimmy Oh
many times I'm a fan favorite I love it
I could see the curtain
[Laughter]
wants to run his Wembley Stadium but I
am III you do because I'm a sports guy
who to boomer and carton and I guess
boomer left and he left him in for good
I think he did yes you're auditioning
guys are one of them's Chris Oh party's
not a bad sports guys love sports I play
them on the fan yeah yeah I played a
celebrity swamp ball game with him and I
was sitting next to them and I look like
Sarah Jessica Parker chubby so lame in
white boomer leave I didn't hear that I
think you realized he has 20 million
dollars in the bank from football I am
on you know I like carton man I like
those guy did the Boomer oh yeah we were
with no you weren't there for I was
there for something else we got Anthony
Bourdain but no they are like great
they're a great sports team they are
they together I'm gonna make an
assumption here they hate each other
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I think when I said hey which one a
feather my cap and I overslept oh my
here's the caveat I made an interview on
time last week with high pitch Eric's
podcast time for that pitch Eric and Jim
Norton Sam Roberts quit when he had
Caroline's by the way I don't know were
supposed to plug her this morning I
forget all right let's say that water
starts or the hours for 3 to 6 go on the
6th you won't see Artie and the 4th
he'll have missed the first night we
should probably the passenger to 1 2 7 5
7 4,100 Artie will sell out he always
sells out August 11th Carnegie Hall that
[ __ ] place that we did together we do
it together in Pittsburgh er no no no no
Bob's doing that I would love to do it
again again with you because we had fun
in Tampa with Tampa together it's fine
when you guys were robbed robbed Kelly
after the gig tried to get me to play in
a band and I said oh [ __ ] what he's
doing drumming yeah yeah Bob was doing
the the [ __ ] gig for our Dennis no
yeah yes yeah yeah he thought he was a
great drummer after like two weeks of
playing the drums yes did you while he
did a drummer off at the house with Fred
from Brooklyn by the way it lost toes to
diabetes and still played the [ __ ] in a
drum support group for no reason like
that one guy built Fenway Park in his
backyard because he met he sold Tim
Allen coke and became his manager but
like guys are Fred from Brooklyn my
house and stuff like that those guys
those guys will always show I we have
money
why they have money like Fred from
Brooklyn what are you doing it's ten
o'clock you've been waiting for four
hours they have like you know like guys
from Tampa who come to shows and
flip-flops and why do you have money
[Laughter]
yeah maybe it's called a work ethic that
when you're flying though like you'll be
in first class and you're looking you'll
see somebody calm down I'm saying I feel
like you look at that like how the [ __ ]
is that
oh man TV I'm gonna match your [ __ ]
named Riley man TV Gucci John's producer
they fight you like this will party in
bel-air guy reduce thriller out loud I
said not even kidding
you have a built-in pool you know funny
people and start to remind me of the the
matarese thing with me we triple-teamed
matter oh my god that was so fun we
weren't gonna go I do I don't know when
he starts reading off cue cards in front
of 11 so what do you do in a situation
are we [ __ ] unloaded yeah but in
fairness they gave Joe such a bit it's
like Joe just didn't know how to handle
that no and he actually came clean he
goes yeah I [ __ ] up I didn't do it
right like he admitted that he [ __ ] it
up like he didn't he's not holding fast
right he's like dude I should adjourn
you know he realizes you invited the
three of us with it
what do you mean fight we were very
comfortable with the green yeah yeah he
did [ __ ] it up and I'll be on that night
on stage which we just were just that
was one of the most fun nights I've ever
had on stage
my years of doing stand-up that going
back and forth and I never made less
money for being never destroyed harder
for free come on guys you're laughing
but JonBenet is still dead she'd have
been pretty hot by now I guess right
obvious elephant elephant look the Olsen
twins got would rise a morning or like
really fast yeah they turned out to be
aliens and I want a jonbenét little late
yeah he got poor joke in a world of [ __ ]
that [ __ ] yeah it's like come on you're
supposed to know how to handle those
situations Ben your comic that's why
people pay to see you on the stage right
right but yeah if Joe Buck has a live
show on HBO you should say second
Cochran but you'll buy everything he
loves you well I think part of it was
that I think he's doing some damage
control like when Howard to rail on me
tow so I'll say I love Rd yeah yeah and
you know I would love it was evil but I
wasn't trying to be evil have you guys
had no communication I don't know his
monster world nothing right no I I
stabbed myself nine times on heroin he
called once and I said listen take care
I think he wanted he was I think he
already made up his mind that he wanted
to do this politically correct show and
I didn't fit in okay to winneth Paltrow
coming in and talking about her green
drink for two hours and I'm shirtless
broom it's a foot from like show her
tits and I think he never won hard to
come to me but I think you heroin did
the job for my way I couldn't go back
for a while and we talked once and and
then Jeff the drunk Errol called me yeah
did you see him at Robin when Robin was
in hospital no but I went to go see him
I just missed all right so back her or
her
aha no I saw Howard that's the only time
I saw him he didn't plan on saying right
just there and the security guard was a
fan it was so funny I walked up because
he's up there you know and I went up
there and we couldn't have we laughed
for like three hours like this [ __ ]
like we're on the air again and then he
that you know I think he just planned on
he has the ability to do that but I know
what he's talking about I mean I became
a full-blown junkie on the biggest radio
show of all time
and that doesn't help the news but I've
never been funnier asleep I was I told
you this Kathy Griffin came on to talk
about how she cried when she told her
mother that she got nominated for an
Emmy and she was crying telling the
story and right in the middle of it you
hear an audible snore for me I've been
dreaming to tell you this dad passed
away but I got no I mean but the idea of
falling asleep on a morning radio shot
mean that you just can't come free oh
yeah shows not exactly the morning dew
in Des Moines your name was on it it was
like that would be like if that was your
show yeah thanks for adding that in ice
leaving you there was really fun that
was one of those things that are just
funny my sleep I'm the girlfriend sad
talk am i sleeping like war like that's
when the honesty comes out oh [ __ ] and
all of a sudden I'm Anthony in Times
Square
talk in my sleep like you're reaching on
my panties yelling or is it your mother
in the face me up and think of Mark
Fuhrman was asleep
I should say which I think represent of
yours over wake me up is it amazing the
[ __ ] look the real [ __ ] mental
patients involved in radio or [ __ ] it's
crazy yeah I was just saying like that
with Howard you have the same way any
rumors leha the we'll all of us as the
Christian Channel so you know naked
beetlejuice talking to a nun thank God
stand-up comics are so much more stable
saying it is the same [ __ ] de
saint-meran
absolutely but radio guys are because
they have to talk for so many hours
that's why there's all this infighting
because you got three hours to kill a
guy says something you got to respond we
talked about I would say to you like you
you know would always you would you do
such a December and weeknights and I
know we see a little bit of how are you
doing that and you're like Wanda's
living healthy right I mean I would
marvel at you doing a Senate like nine
o'clock in the comedies but I would also
marvel at you I'll be coming in with
Artie and I'm just as tired and he's got
he's on heroin with sunglasses I'm
literally bumping into him on the
elevator
wow we both made choices and at the
exact same reserved barely making this
[ __ ] show I I really can't believe
like I'm lamenting about the fact that I
missed an interview with the governor I
might need to make a phone call in jail
I have one day for some sort of reprieve
it's good to have the governor on your
side oh god yeah yeah you know yeah he
has the pictures I have nine celebrities
rebel game and just an enormous ask you
know like the camel toe [ __ ] yeah he
looks like Tweedledee
he's got four you got male camel toe
yeah yes someone should have told him
before he walked out of that [ __ ]
dugout yeah I guess I go that's not him
everywhere I mean there was some guy
like last week he was filling in for
Francesa and some guy called oh yeah
they were booing him and I think at the
Mets game
game yes everywhere you go well-financed
don't go to work for Francesa - it's
interchangeable yeah you know what I had
a joke - I was gonna say you know you
got me off heroin for a week my drug
dealer was in the Bronx and it was like
for three days traffic look at him
that's you don't go out in those pants
didn't he used to play baseball though
like this picture high school Chelsea
Handler that did that look only is good
in baseball if it's black and white and
you're running in Fast blacks weren't
playing yet yeah he was fun to talk so
he was trying to be like hip and cool
when he told ya he talking about I score
Chelsea and I said any funny people come
out was it gonna be sports or just
anything some sports but that he's like
this big opiate thing you know okay yeah
yeah so that would have been fun to get
grilled on that I didn't ask you about
anything yeah I think he I think you
wanted to yeah good for him then I avoid
it
yeah I was I was going to say if you
ever get another partner opiate and
Anthony opiate and Anthony really wants
that job does you really want a job I
think it's weird it's almost like if you
imagine having a responsibility being
the governor then you can just want to
talk about whatever you like what's it
they want the power like there's a power
today they just want to they want to
have the voice still listen to me yeah
it's a narcissistic thing politics sure
she guys were more blue-collar Howard
did love like that going to Danielle the
French planes are getting a table and
[ __ ] like that oh that was obvious yeah
yeah you know you guys could have got
into Joey's anyway yeah
and I still felt cool about it we've got
a table of chilies great what is be sure
we have yeah yeah this really was like
the [ __ ] the gutter swamp [ __ ]
well I said like somehow he got a fans
had jobs it was the morning you guys
were the hardcore oh yeah yeah the ATO's
animals wha-what was going on between
you and John because I I was hit
stuttering John at the Comedy Cellar one
night and he's sitting at the table and
he's telling me how he's gonna kick your
ass if he's sitting there and he's going
if Artie walks in hit that door I will
[ __ ] kick his head kidding or no no
he was pretty serious and then he left
so we've gone downstairs Bill Schulz was
hanging out I think we went down to
watch the show and and John left or got
kicked out or something and then I go
back upstairs and then here comes Artie
yeah Artie comes in and I'm like [ __ ]
man that would have been awesome yeah
yeah I would like to see that what's the
fair he can't take it he dishes out we
can't take it you know he always thought
he wanted that chairs over the beginning
there was tension and you're you mean
yeah this well he was Jackie's chair I
guess at the time yeah but I you know
and then I think he was there was like
sort of a thing going on there and then
we started doing the road together and
you know he had a very competitive thing
and then on the air at the at the pot at
my podcast we were talking about how el
chapo el chapo coming out of prison get
the job interviewing other King
[Laughter]
and you got very mad effect that's so I
don't imagine him getting mad at
anything that's so funny
and then you do a man couple with him
because because when he gets in a battle
of the which we would all beat them
Florentine me it would be like you know
it would throw no-hitters on the road
and you know I'm like oh sick battling
hypodermic or you know okay see I don't
know where it got to the like physically
Porto Rican in half damage I was used to
did you get any of the Danish did you
get any of the [ __ ] day I love the
guy I have a lot of we have stories
where he's looking endearing guy yeah
and you know he went when you're on a
JetBlue flight with him and his hair is
in your eggs cuz he falls asleep but he
still of the long hair is I got here not
love ago yeah you know on Twitter said I
hear Jim and sama bad-mouthing me can
you call I texted him I'm like we're
friends you could have just texted me
what about what a bad mouth you yeah I
got a bad mouth you on the radio yeah
what are you talking right he's one of
those I she's almost like a fan you know
we meet a fan and this is indigenous or
some Philly fans they meet you and they
like it cuz your blue collar I like you
know your regular saying I like you guys
you're a loser
yeah for an hour and then it's and as
soon as you go well I gotta get a kid
John's like that guy nobody's like a
co-worker really I love I love the guy
and chapo does look like exactly you
can't go on Twitter though and take
anything that they say about other
people talking about you and stuff -
tweeted something someone goes Anthony
you should go out to California go on
Joe Rogan's show and I tweeted I go well
I guess I have to do that the
[ __ ] won't come on my show in
New York and
obviously that's look he's busy he's
this he's that
no I know that that and and I was
totally kidding when I wrote that Riya I
would never I've only written nice
things about Joe I love Joe Rogan we had
a lot of hacks with Twitter but they see
it and people like oh now you got a
[ __ ] problem with Joe Rogan like no
I'm just [ __ ] goofy written telephone
game and they want to start a few that's
what they want to do it like Esther ku I
guess was on Ellis's show yeah so much
sent a video and goes oh man Esther's
testa and Ellis are ripping you apart
no like wait and then you listen to it
and go there's not a second where she's
ripping me no Esther Esther likes you a
lot
she also likes me very much she's a
[ __ ] how many condoms can you fit up
your that's such a funny [ __ ] bit man
but but but he did what makes it work is
he L Chapel looks exactly like John
exactly the first time I saw his picture
I was like what the [ __ ] is John Doe
what did John do
it's John wood business funny if John
attacked me in the middle of a crowded
Comedy Cellar
it wouldn't an atom ins breaking us up
minutes minutes out of it awesome that
would be a yeah that's why I was kind of
like oh [ __ ] she found him
yeah take him I don't know at this point
my body my body's ravaged in 1986 I
think I got it
now I guess he was also pissed that
people were making fun of his run for
Senate
okay okay okay stop right there
stuttering John yeah the guy the guy who
used to ask Ted Williams if he ever know
Yogi Berra if you ever got hit with
balls in the face the guy used to it was
said to a Melanie Griffith how's your
father Andy doing the guy who asked the
astronaut time I explained if you ever
ran off a batch in the innokentiy okay
wants to run for Senate and ask
comedians we're not allowed to make fun
of that yeah grow up man I mean what
would you tell her about me come on that
is that is yeah we're gonna make fun of
it and I'll make fun of it again comics
and radio people we said it before you
came in all [ __ ] mental patients like
we all have weird Achilles heels like
what guess it's just crazy access
sensitive because radio people are so
absolutely yeah we just don't show it as
much we don't have four hours a day to
talk I'm trying to think whose more like
twisted weird
I might think comics are but radio
people can be really oversensitive about
things you know that's what you want
talking about low-level radio guys like
in Wyoming who want to [ __ ] the chicken
works at the tire place right where she
looks like guys have started motorcycles
on her chest they never really they get
weird they get weird into a bigger
market you know it becomes they're in
jail forever eventually yeah but comics
I think it a little more
I don't know cynical and jaded and don't
don't do weird okay yeah I could see
that yeah more jaded and cynical right I
think radio guys are more insecure about
losing their spot because they there's
entire yeah everybody is plenty of
comics but like like you can just go
every three months your job is in
jeopardy right ratings books that's
right right it's like it drives you
batshit when I first took my first
ratings book at Howard I didn't realize
this to one of my [ __ ] buddies
pointed out in the background it goes
you know
how are you saying okay let me start the
first rating book comes out and I'm
happy I got the job and my buddy goes
you know you could the show could only
go down and who's gonna get blamed for
that so that first book comes out I'm
like oh my god like thank God it was
fine it was number one again but if it
was number four oh man like sometimes
she sounds gonna come what's different
yeah oh you too big on it that was the
most nerve-wracking thing in terrestrial
radio was that the ratings coming out
and you'd be like alright can we
oh and then you'd hear well our demo was
good and this saturated this Harlem with
Brooks
so the [ __ ] rap station did well and
think you just like do I have a [ __ ]
job for 20 more months [ __ ] that's what
people don't understand like there's
nothing to worry about it that's serious
unless you're fine if you don't
photograph a woman or treat your chest
like a pin cushion off-label and report
on the water at forty eight and nine
[Laughter]
this job to like just being a problem
some sort man we have more shots and
yeah you know what's hilarious they were
basically saying you could say the
n-word on air but not off I just told
him earlier in the show I got kicked off
I got kicked off a Twitter recently and
what a badge of honor I would love that
just get kicked off yeah but when I got
fired from here yeah for what I tweeted
Twitter didn't kick me off that right
right but I got fired for it yeah yeah
I know some things are gonna make you
mad if you're a comic for 30 years ago
I'm defriend than you ala day I'll be
able to get down that flue Sicilian
slice you're defending me at baby shower
sometimes to follow boycott I'm selling
all your DVDs really
oh you blocked me a real freedom of
speech guy like but what your freedom of
speech to call me a [ __ ] lump of [ __ ]
is something I should deal with the
[Laughter]
University punch me in the face friend
wasn't a verb I'm going to friend you
yeah I'm gonna blow me Matthew Perry but
it does you know it's funny it does get
you on some well you somebody said they
did some very funny just celebrities
somebody said that they would go to
celebrities and just we blocked them
like wine bottle probably man on their
insecurities rocked by a few people
Nancy Grace is the main one who a not
even blame her for blocking me like she
was the one you were the bomb show
tonight was it was it after her
appearance on no show a before that what
happened
I had bashed her many times publicly I
think she sucks she started crying on
your show right no I'm not crying but
she kind of just walked off she's gotta
get get serious now yeah somewhat we can
cross-promotion no we should get on
there sure she called us this is like
our third week of doing the show right
thing and she went on the view and said
I didn't know I was gonna do an
interview with beavis and butthead you I
do the obstructed view
yeah she oh she would get on the [ __ ]
on whatever show she was on what was
that CNN I would just be like another
episode with tot mom Casey Anthony big
tits of hers
boy she's with her lawyer oh I could
have [ __ ] would you gotta write baby
no lawyer Kent I'll just be like Joe
keep keep the kids away and fight her I
cuz she was she was looking for a place
to live for a while he said I got room I
remember you well she was thinking but
she found you too emotionally unhealthy
Casey Anthony I want a hug the worst
insult you've ever given me
wait a minute good one needle nose yeah
see I I would I have no problem I would
absolutely if the things happen I would
[ __ ] Casey over my house who cares I
don't have kids found guilty I still
wouldn't care
yeah by the way let me get Anthony cou
Mia every day Monday through Thursday on
compound media of course as you know you
can catch Eastside Dave do you know
biscotti and Aaron McKinney McGinnis yes
darks are black guy haptics Dixon does
the New York City Crime Report and
Anthony's new Twitter is Anthony Kumi X
Y Z of course RT is party Twitter on
Twitter RT quitter and August here in
Caroline's August 3 through 5 go to RT
quitter comm for his dates but
Caroline's already is gonna sell out
these are no curtain in the middle of
the room chose to 7 5 7 4 just don't
forget to make sure Lee both will still
keep chatty I just I feel I'm plucks I'm
so going to that I I am too but I
haven't seen you live in so long I want
to come and see your new set well you
know you're gonna have to wait the next
show show
I'm going to see gilben I see 1978 Yeah
right he is so that show you guys did
together it was the live version of his
podcast I think that was Caroline's I
got kicked off the festival but it was
so [ __ ] funny
like like hurting hurting laughing funny
have you ever done the road with him Jim
like a real show with Gilbert where you
guys are you know Carly or whatever and
see how we really many years ago you
know I I've done I've gotten to know him
from the Comedy Cellar I've driven him
home a lot and I've just spent time
talking to him and it's it's so did I
got guy how are you whenever came out 91
you're watching Aladdin and you go the
genie and the parrot one is going to
commit suicide he really has a sweetness
to him we're like yeah you know I think
he's so funny
but and he he came to me once he really
is there in Brazil he really is the
cheap thing is not even exaggerating oh
he says Lee I picked up I picked up his
uh his bag because he was just standing
there waiting for you to pick up his bag
yeah and a zipper was open and all these
non-dairy creamers oh no diner
he's got that just went all over the
like he like it wasn't even embarrassed
but I just started laughing hysterically
he stole like 50 creamers and like I
don't know what the state of it what are
you gonna do with them these crazy the
[ __ ] pack rat not about the creamers
at that point yeah that's not right
stories it is fun man yeah oh yeah and
he knows everything about like old
movies yeah right time of wasted youth
that was in the festival that you and it
won best village I wanted a best show on
the buzz if you were there
watching that live you saw something
amazing it was so [ __ ] funny but you
know I do have new [ __ ] and but but like
Jim like the Trump stuff like what are
you doing where do you stop do you even
do it I do too it's such a beach ball
coming in it's like what it's so crazy
it's easy Joker eyes hair right up and I
go oh careful the president might fire
everybody what are you guys almost like
it's hard and easy right yeah everything
has been exhausted with it it's like
there's what new angle are you gonna get
off of Donald Trump no I I just I don't
kill him on stage Lee I make fun of him
a little bit and some of the stuff he
said but I also say I don't hate him and
that people see if you're gonna hate him
hate him for the right reasons I try to
call out a little the [ __ ] in the
anti-trump stuff like I think a lot of
it is just they think they're supposed
to so I I do it that way I mean it
literally is and that's ballsy too
because I do this everybody I think you
know it really cost people work like
that's yeah that pisses me off so much
as the hypocrisy of like it cost people
work acting jobs it's just saying it's
kinda like them
I've seen people just back away and fear
from a conversation on my show you know
comics will come on or somebody and be
like oh yeah I'm not gonna talk about
that I mean why not they're petrified
right yeah I can't even blame them
though yeah but you're right to is are
you just an actor not a comical create
words yeah yeah it's a legitimate
concern yeah
yeah fractures it's hard we talked about
this who we haven't we talked about the
acting Oh [ __ ] Steve Guttenberg was
in yesterday yes and it's just I hear he
has a big juicy heavy caca Hawaii say
that again fits together and they did
the old joke like you know what I'm
sorry I look like foster Brooks so like
supposedly Jack warden and him were at
the Friars Club Guttenberg and the
Guttenberg did the joke where I you know
let's see who's longer and he said I'm
only going to pull
enough to win he told milton berle the
true stories joke we're not in the
contest no he said I don't bro no deej I
heard he said Milty just to pull out
enough to him and I believe because he
was like a guy's guy Jackie Gleason oh
yeah
he didn't want [ __ ] broads around
like you know he wanted to hang with the
boys and smoke probably I've seen his
[ __ ] since before yeah he probably was
like half [ __ ] it was with a guy from
F Troop that contest oh yeah yeah yeah I
just met him I went to the Gilbert
screen and court I did an interview and
I would you know you're [ __ ]
finishing showbiz when you get cut out
of the Gilbert documentary interview so
you mean the other guy yeah it's the
other guy yeah the other guy had a huge
dick something Bob Crane yeah the two
Indians from Hogan's Heroes did remember
huge films that crane had a big dick
nobody just was a perverted [ __ ]
big cocky nude film himself [ __ ]
girls and he got killed in some weird
circumstances he had a tripod I know
that Jay was beaten to death with a
tripod by his partner you know yeah how
awkward it is to hold a tripod be
someone who keeps faulty on your hands
well first of all you know if being on
Hogan's Heroes is not enough excitement
for you
just think though like what he would
have thought of today where you just
hold your phone up and take you got a
breakout equipment like a production was
going on Scott Peterson today yes he was
what a weirdo like I really was a weird
guy what a focus is a good job by Greg
Kinnear and I guess Willem Dafoe plays
the other guy put some of the creepiest
scenes I've ever seen in my life like
like you know how bad do you want an
Oscar Greg Kinnear
he just such a jerk and was really hot
and I'm going like you know no I'd say
the doctor no I'm I quit actually doing
yeah he will go in there and he's like
this is really hot and willing to fo you
can obviously willem dafoe the guy who
you know did anything going I'm not I
don't want this part this is too creepy
yeah
that's willem dafoe a saying it's too
creepy
that's [ __ ] I told I thought I did
this awful shitty movie called boat trip
with Will Ferrell and Cooper getting and
we shot in Cologne Germany because of
money and there was a sink nobody will
fell play Germany smells good - oh [ __ ]
we exhaust all down Joe and I had I so I
said to the director there gonna be 20
grand for today and at the end it says
already kisses we'll all ready kiss on
the lips and I said to the regulars
don't waste your time
I have Italian uncles I'm not kissing
any God I pulled the Kevin Hart hey
Kevin art said he would never kiss again
like that one of the almost kind of a
fist fight was directed for making I got
no problem any buddy but I'm not gonna
kiss will and I know we'll do anything
so don't get me over the [ __ ] Cologne
Germany with two lay overs and give me
20 G's and expect me to do it we go to
Cologne Germany
I got a layover I'm on the Autobahn with
Vivica Fox who and her gay assistant who
made me hate gay people war you got a
man you got a man just the two of us on
the Autobahn we get there and sure
enough it comes time for the saying goes
you gonna do it right I said I told you
oh I said I'm a Guinea from Jersey I'm
not kissing my lips so will for an hour
and a half is on camera trying to kiss
me on the lips and he's pulling me to it
filming filming finally they let him
gives me on the cheek and at the last
second he got me on the lips and that's
a [ __ ] hot story dude but mighty only
[ __ ] if not so fast but thank God there
was an intern in the shot they couldn't
use it
I said that's Karma you know Smith said
he regretted I think he said in six
degrees separation he wouldn't kiss the
other actor he said that was one of his
regrets that he wished he had in the
movie that was a good movie I got built
one time by someone who said they were
Sidney Poitier son at you because he
does get built by people that say there
oh yeah
move though a great mood cause you're
playing on that like rich white people
guilted like you know yeah he's the and
he was always a black guy to go to like
well I'd like to send apply yeah yeah
the question was always would you want
your daughter married Charles Manson or
city by angle of course anybody so that
was a what a great [ __ ] move on a con
man's board that was a great movie to
and who was that Stockard Channing and
Donald Sutherland brunette right yeah
he's dr. chanting right before you
started to look like a wallet I really
bought her as a high school student
increase in menopause yes she was a
little too but then again Olivia
newton-john was in a [ __ ] 30s
actually she got breast cancer yeah I
don't know if she still that I made fun
of her first I think I've seen her in
interviews recently she's still around
find her husband who disappeared or some
[ __ ] crazy but in other words the John
Travolta is equally attracted to her now
as it was that exactly he actually jerks
don't think about her husband oh my poor
Johnny T hey do you want to work out
together he had spent three o'clock in
the morning in [ __ ] Dallas
that doesn't seem fishy this team limit
the guy from [ __ ] grease you know like
you're not chasing [ __ ] if you have
time to put a pilot uniform on and land
a 737 in your bag yeah did you have your
eyes that he liked that plane because
you can have a co-pilot then you could
also uh and then do whatever you want
for a little while and no one would know
like if you're the only two people on a
plane at 35,000 feet pretty secure you
could suck each other my [ __ ] will fall
down put my [ __ ] in your mouth before
putting it in a child
what a great setup though man if you got
to [ __ ] it what he just takes him on the
plane before you take off sure why not
Jake's on the plane took less time to be
Jimmy's fan fiction over here yeah if
you want a plane when you don't want
everyone to know how to [ __ ] John
Travolta on a plane he is so bad at like
pretending not to be gay
yeah I remember Patrese talking about
his big comeback like like pulp fiction
was his comeback right and it's like
wasn't a comeback it was the only good
movie he made yeah everything he's done
since then right right for them
then kind of sucked that's a good point
like come by usually all those guys are
making good movies like how could look
who's talking to not get me something
yeah yeah if we got offered a guy like
Tarantino comes along was into nostalgia
yeah and get give him apart and then he
pumped out after that just [ __ ] [ __ ]
that stupid Scientology movie and pump
checks and it was back phenomenal Mike
don't like come on yeah yeah chick
movies and what else has he done since a
pulp fiction I mean do you know what he
was good and get shorty usually get
shorty that was kind of a cool role yeah
when he was Michael the angel the angel
what's that about yeah that's all you
really need to know and then of course
my favorite of all time face-off you
know what the technology is good but I
love it the interviews for that are so
funny because [ __ ] Nicholas Cage is
so mad that he set up a great character
for for him to mimic yeah yeah and
Travolta's getting all accolades and
like you could tell the egos of actors
cage is really man in the interview well
I mean I gave him every day I gave he
gave me no it's like double bad because
it's Travolta yeah
acting like Nic Cage is bad cubed or
squared
any think you got a [ __ ] daughter
yeah yeah that but he doesn't
[ __ ] the wife or something how about
your voter in the readers for the script
we make it as summer but doesn't fit the
character no it would he's evil he's
terrible that's you know that's what
John got pissed off stuttering John
auditioning this he got really mad at me
and Fred auditioning for the night show
they gave him celebrities to introduce
okay ones Nicolas Cage he says the
n-word in his audition for the night
because he can't pronounce a Nicholas he
says he's got a speech impediment gets
the single most coveted voice of a job
in the history of television
yeah and he doesn't think that you could
we can't goof on that and he says
Nicholas kick-starter the intro sir no I
don't really well it's clearly had a
retake them yeah you know sometimes and
he made him a writer which was just a
you know gimme thing I used to see him
when I'd go out there and blown a show
happen to John nice guy but you know and
we were really good friends but he's got
it he would give it but he couldn't take
it that was the problem
mm-hm yeah you got to realize when you
[ __ ] up or you do something crazy like
your friends are gonna go fine it's part
of it right we might want to Keith
Robinson stroke and he doesn't you know
anything it is what it is yeah but
that's it like like busting balls and
[ __ ] people are your friends and
everything but the seller is so did I
mean it you know it's a Yankee state has
a cratenbarrel wedding showers of the
seventh-inning stretch is it called
Pepsi field you know the salad table
should just be like you know okay it's a
guy code table yeah it's not the same
venom they used to be someone said the
other day on my show they were saying
that this girl was angry because she
wasn't getting support in the stand-up
comic community with the community
there's a stand-up comic community
they never actually go on stage I'm just
sitting around talking about how their
comics and who's good and bad and
judging everything but they never
actually get up because they have
nothing
I've never mind if I'm in it I want to
be kicked out right what are you doing
on the next season of crashing well you
should you should tweet the community
again I was in five event later I think
I'm in six of eight this year okay it's
actually appetite was feeding off what
other people have found like yeah I'll
write my own loser stuff you just have
to watch my life and yeah we're gonna do
you know it's like been very good to me
impatient it's amazing yeah so I you
know we just continue with me trying to
toughen up Pete and he tries to save me
with interventions and so I was so
pissed off at at crashing because I I
read appetize tweets and everything I'm
like [ __ ] guy I don't really I don't
really care the guy gave me a job but
I'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] that show [ __ ]
and then I'm like alright I'm gonna
watch it he hires everybody Jimmy Jimmy
how to i watch the [ __ ] thing yeah
the whole thing like I watched it all in
the night one night and I'm like
[ __ ] not like this because I I
was so mad at Judds like [ __ ] on
Twitter but well Twitter dangers
everywhere really is its high years to
get back in this seat like he did is
like like it was it's cool that me and
you haven't seen together in a show yeah
yeah and I mean to tell have the same
kind of thing you know that part is fun
and Johnny's very tires than that but
but the I I've you know he just lets the
it's a guy would power yeah and I've
been on but he's got four cameras
rolling wolf 35-millimeter they never
stop they shoot it like a play so you
see the difference
the difference between a guy and Hoboken
who gets my
from Russian mafia to do a film and and
a guy with power and they give him money
and executives on the set not allowed to
talk Wow and you know that's that's I've
never been involved up like that that
was a fun scene to do another art if you
could make it happen strip club and show
that yeah and Pete is really good I love
here yeah about the fact that like when
comics that are you know peers of all
all the community the older community
now he sort of lays back and oh you guys
do your thing you know it was fun but
it's also that was so much fun I mean
I'd love to do it again if you have any
influence over Democrats but guess what
there is a part though I
he's from it that he's from a very
different part of stand-up like you
don't know you really just 40,000 guys
that you never heard of were comics who
judge you mean like monkey Largo
oh yeah Oh see you know there's a lot of
guys you know like I mean a comedian for
39 ever heard of a guy who's got like
eight special yeah six hundred thousand
Twitter followers ah there's a whole
nother world right about there yeah yeah
so you know he's part of that too you
know and and it's just it's fun because
to a mainstream showing that coming
along a floor in the lab I got some
blood work back and you know it's gonna
be good for the Lance Rocke blood work
he all right you know I don't know I
gave your example that had a worm in it
from a tequila yeah III luck flour bad I
got my liver enzymes when I went in it
was a crazy and my cholesterol level was
a baby whose lifetime slugging
percentage everything went down today so
this operation I just had I'm gonna be
healthier you said you're gonna feel
better and you just gotta stop abusing
yourself but not verbally do you ever
think you could though like you ever
think like all right man I'm had a lot
I've taken a lot of shots across the bow
I know I have you know
but do you ever think of it like man I
just gotta [ __ ] it one day just go [ __ ]
it I'm done doing all that stuff and
like just kind of move forward yeah yeah
you know it's just funny well I've been
in three relationships that were five
years of peace and you think that's
gonna that's gonna work until these
[ __ ] make you choose between heroin
and them I think that's a being it
doesn't get the wrong person I don't
know I I have not figured it out I have
not figured out life clearly yeah and I
don't think a person can save you from
anything right another maybe temporarily
get your [ __ ] together because you know
you want to keep [ __ ] her like you
know went the way I would have went up
and get lucky working construction they
trying to take me down these young girls
oh you know you guys don't like to say
movies what it's all about and I got
listen Anthony I'll make you a deal I
want anything French is coming in a way
and like that can all the guys in
punchline I'm in love with the lady
comedy Oh
worst line ever girls your eyes crying
yeah but great if I could get better or
anyone out of that like I'm just gonna
be an annoying guy telling you not you
know drinking's a dead-end street no you
know what I I understand that you think
that all the sudden the demons make us
funnier like without them I'm not me as
a comedian if I stop [ __ ] do all this
sexual [ __ ] but it's not true it's
almost like that stuff blocks even
though I've used it to be funny and you
used it that's not what you do users I
think you're just saying look I'm being
honest about my life and I I'm a good
look Jim what you do there's a lot of
people who would make that not funny
crazy [ __ ] funny it's that's a talent
you know well I don't want to be too
funny that's why I you know drinking Wow
[Laughter]
the rule here tonight just open the
bottle it's just as easy when we were
doing afternoons at any W I would have a
couple of beers behind the monitor yes
yeah and then when we we went to
morning's I really did have this kind of
a can I even do radio yeah I wasn't
getting falling down drunk but a little
buzzed it's hard but then you know got
into it it was what it was what it was
it was we had a great time but I I
thought it took at 7:00 a.m. okay yeah
that was even me at some I can't [ __ ]
get drunk in the morning can't do it and
then you realize it's like a life is
well for everything like you know if you
get success in this business and you're
you know you're drinking on the job
everything a guidance counselor told you
is wrong then you go if I have a kid
what I'm gonna tell them the reason
you're in private school is I got drunk
I'm a [ __ ] air high school dropout
come in and talk about being pissed on
the next morning no one ever told me
that's gonna make you a lot of money
apartment there's a lot of people who
would really not make that funny you
know those Chuck Berry tapes I you know
I would combine the two I would show my
eight-year-old kid Chuck Berry pissing
in a chick's mouth and going that guy
wrote you honey me